7 ngày trước, Google đã làm một điều mà mình không thể ngờ tới.
Họ đã tách Antigravity ra làm 2,
là Antigravity IDE và Antigravity 2.0.
Video này mình sẽ cho bạn thấy chính xác nó khác gì so với
phiên bản cũ và những tính năng mới mà Google đã thêm vào.
Mình là Nam, kỹ sư phần mềm cấp cao tại FIS,
một trong những công ty fintech hàng đầu thế giới. Mình đã dùng Antigravity
từ những ngày đầu để tự động hóa gần như toàn bộ công việc
văn phòng của mình. nên khi Google ra bản 2.0 mình đã test ngay
lập tức. Sau video này bạn sẽ biết chính xác Antigravity khác gì,
những tính năng nào bạn cần dùng, và quan trọng hơn,
bạn sẽ biết cách tận dụng để tiết kiệm hàng giờ làm việc
mỗi tuần. Ok, hãy bắt đầu luôn nha.
câu hỏi đầu tiên ai cũng thắc mắc là Antigravity 2.0 khác gì so
với Antigravity IDE. Trước đây,
Antigravity nó như là một cái IDE,
Integrated Development Environment.
Thay vào đó, bạn vào đó bạn sẽ thấy toàn bộ File,
Folder, Code Editor. Nó mạnh nhưng mà nó chỉ dành cho dân lập trình.
Nếu bạn không phải là dev, khi bạn mở nó lên bạn sẽ thấy
chóng mặt. Khi bạn mở nó lên bạn sẽ thấy toàn là folder,
file hoặc là config như thế này. Và mình nghĩ Google đã nhận ra
điều đó. Họ nhận ra rằng AI không chỉ dành cho lập trình viên
mà AI dành cho tất cả mọi người lên Antigravity 2.0 ra đời
như một triết lý hoàn toàn khác. Thay vì đặt file folder ở trung
tâm, họ đặt Google sẽ đặt AI ở trung tâm.
bạn không cần phải mở File Folder lên để chỉnh sửa hay là làm
gì mà bạn chỉ cần nói chuyện với AI AI sẽ toàn bộ
hiểu và chỉnh sửa cho bạn. Nói ngắn gọn.
Antigravity. Anti-Gravity IDE là dành cho dân lập trình hoặc là developer và Anti-Gravity
2.0 là dành cho tất cả mọi người.
để cài đặt Anti-Gravity 2.0 mình phải làm như thế nào?
Bây giờ mình sẽ mở Google lên,
vào phần Anti-Gravity Google và mình vào phần Download.
Mình chỉ cần download cái file này cho Windows Mình sẽ tự động download
AntiGravity 2.0 thay vì download AntiGravity IDE như trước
đây. Sau khi bạn tải thành công,
Bạn chỉ cần mở file của bạn lên và chạy cái file AntiGravity này.
Sau khi setup xong, bạn sẽ có một cái ứng dụng Anti-Gravity như thế
này. Ok, vậy mình có thể dùng nó để làm gì?
Đây là 4 tính năng mới mình nghĩ bạn sẽ dùng hàng ngày.
Đầu tiên, khi bạn mở Anti-Gravity lên,
bạn chỉ cần tạo một folder, tạo một project mới.
Cái project mới này dựa trên một folder của bạn.
Bây giờ bạn sẽ chọn một folder. Mình sẽ chọn một folder ngẫu nhiên
ở trên file của mình là Donghu Convert.
và mình select folder và mình chỉ cần tạo cái folder là xong.
Ok, mình đã tạo một cái folder. Bây giờ mình sẽ nói qua cho
những tính năng mới mà Google vừa thêm vào.
Tính năng đầu tiên là quản lý cấp phép của project.
Sau khi bạn tạo một project, bạn có thể mở cái project này lên
để bạn quản lý xem quyền cấp phép của project này thế nào.
Bây giờ mình sẽ chọn project document của mình. Bạn có thể thấy đây,
đây là agent setting. Đây là quản lý quyền cấp phép của cái project
này. Bạn có thể chọn nó là full machine,
có thể chạy tất cả comment của trên máy của bạn,
có thể đọc và tất cả, quản lý tất cả các file của bạn.
Và quyền cấp phép này là quyền Unrestricted là ta có thể chạy toàn
bộ tất cả mọi thứ, không cần có những safety nào,
bảo mật an toàn nào cả. Mình sẽ chạy chọn Unregistered trong
cái project này của mình. Và đây là Agent Behavior tính năng quản
lý xem agent của mình sẽ phải như thế nào sau khi
mỗi lần mà nó muốn thay đổi hoặc là sửa hoặc là tạo những
file thì nó có thể tự động hỏi mình hoặc là mình có thể
cho nó quyền cấp phép luôn mình không cần phải trả lời những câu
hỏi của nó nữa. mình đang để Always Approved không cần phải không cần
phải hỏi mình nữa những tính năng quản lý cấp phép của project sẽ
đến là đến Permission,
rồi đến Customization. Đây là tính năng quản lý skill
của cái project này của bạn. Như bạn thấy đây,
cái project của mình đang có, document của mình đang có 3 skill mình
đã tạo cho cái document này của mình.
skill sẽ được tạo phải dựa trên cái pattern là .agent
rồi đến skill rồi đến cái name của cái skill của bạn rồi đến
cái skill MD là file skill của bạn đó mình đã tạo 3 skill
cho cái folder này của mình để quản lý bộ chế Check này sẽ
quản lý 3 cái skill này Ok,
sau khi xong 2 tính năng đầu rồi, mình sẽ đến demo thực tế
luôn. Bây giờ mình sẽ làm một cái Word, file Word ở trên cái
document project này của mình. Mình giới thiệu sơ qua cái document này project
của mình. Là mình có một folder document và mình có tất
cả những file như là file Word, chương trình liên kết,
file Excel, file PowerPoint. Bây giờ mình sẽ làm việc với file Excel
này. Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo AI để preview cái
file này. mình sẽ không thể đọc được file này.
Bây giờ mình phải tạo một lệnh để con AI của mình để đọc
cái file này. Bây giờ mình sẽ tạo một lệnh là hãy tạo một
MD file để mình có thể để được xem thử cái file Excel này,
xem nó có tạo cho mình được không anh nha Ok,
nó đã tạo cho mình 1 cái file MD file để mình mở lên
xem cái file Excel này của mình như thế nào nha Đây là cái
file trong Excel của mình đây Nó đã tạo 1 số thứ như thế
này Cột đầu tiên là cột sẽ như thế này,
cột thứ 2 là như thế này Bây giờ mình sẽ thay đổi một
số thứ ở trên cái pha Excel này của mình. Mình thấy cái tính
năng này rất là hay với Google Antigravity.
Bây giờ mình sẽ highlight cái đoạn này, mình sẽ bảo là thay vì
34.000$ Bây giờ mình sẽ chuyển thành 20.000 đô,
đó. Mình sẽ add cái comment này đây.
Rồi tiếp theo mình sẽ làm một số thứ như là bảo nó là
OK, nó sẽ tính số tiền này là,
nó sẽ tính số tiền này là đây, tính số tiền tổng cộng là
3.000 đô đây.
Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo nó là Hãy explain cho mình cái value này.
Ok, sau khi mình ad một số comment của mình vào cái file này
xem, bây giờ mình sẽ bảo ChatGPT chạy xem nó sẽ chạy như
thế nào nha. Nó sẽ có thể thay đổi từ 34.000 thành 20.000
không hoặc là nó có thể explain cho mình xem cái số tiền
này tại sao như vậy không. Ok,
nó đã hoàn thành xong và nó đã bảo là nó đã sửa cái
file dựa theo cái comment này của mình nó đã sửa cái file này
từ của từ 34.000 thành 20.000 đô và nó đã trả lời
là tại sao tổng nợ này là 3.067
đô như này Tiền nợ này là tổng tiền nợ trả nợ của 1
năm gồm nợ vay sinh viên là 1.671
trên 1 năm và nợ vay mua xe là 1.396 trên 1 năm Ok,
bây giờ mình sẽ mở cái file này ở trên folder của mình xem
nó có thay đổi đúng hay không nha Ok,
con AI của mình đã thay đổi cho mình từ 34.000 xuống còn 20.000
đô và chính xác theo những gì mà mình đã sửa ở trên Markup
File. Và đó là skill khi mà mình làm việc với AI
qua Anti-Gravity. Ok,
tính năng thứ cuối cùng của Anti-Gravity mới được thêm vào là tính năng
đặt lịch Schedule Task. Hôm qua mình đã đặt một cái
prompt đặt lịch một cái task là cứ mỗi 9 giờ sáng nó
sẽ phải bật máy lên và kiểm tra giá vàng hôm nay ở trên
kênh 24h.com giá vàng.
Bây giờ mình sẽ mở lên xem hôm nay nó check giá vàng của
mình như thế nào nha. Ok đây là giá vàng mà nó check cho
mình hôm nay, là giá vàng SGC là 157.700
và giá vàng bán là 160.700
Đây là những giá vàng mà nó đã tự động lên mạng tìm kiếm
giá vàng cho mình. Để tạo một task như thế này,
bạn chỉ cần vào schedule task và bạn chỉ cần tạo một news và
bạn muốn tên task như Ví dụ như là Website hoặc là cái gì
đó Sau đó bạn chỉ cần tạo cho cái project này và mấy giờ
bạn sẽ chạy, ví dụ mình sẽ chọn một chiều đi
đúng không? Bây giờ mình sẽ chỉ cần viết cái prompt này,
ví dụ lên mạng tìm kiếm cái gì đó,
tìm kiếm Thời tiết ngày hôm nay.
Đó. Chỉ cần tạo 1 task là add schedule là xong.
Nó sẽ tự động tạo 1 task cho mình. và mỗi lần một
tờ chiều nó sẽ lên mạng và tìm kiếm tờ tiết hôm nay như
thế nào. Đó là bốn tính năng của AntiGravity.
Vậy là bạn đã biết AntiGravity nó khác gì so với IDE cũ ra
sao. Bốn tính năng mới bạn có thể dùng ngay hôm nay và Google
đang đặt AI vào trung tâm. Và mình nghĩ đây mới chỉ là điều
bắt đầu. Nếu bạn muốn tìm hiểu thêm về cách dùng AntiGravity hay
để tự động hóa, Mình có những video hướng dẫn ở trên kênh của
mình, PieLikeClaw. Mình còn làm nhiều video về Antigravity như
là tạo web hay chỉnh sửa prompts. Để không bỏ lỡ video này,
hãy đăng Like, Subscribe cho mình nha.
Thank you.